we often talk about the top meta issues
in the world of politics in our economy
in our culture and I often name campaign
finance I talk about Internet freedom we
talk about economic justice and
inequality and I mention climate change
because if your cities underwater that's
really bad for the economy if people are
dying from heat that's really bad for
the economy we've talked about that
before and of course the current
President believes that climate change
isn't real or if it's real it's not
caused by humans or it's a hoax created
by the Chinese we've heard basically
every version of climate denial from the
current President of the United States
and I've been making the point that
aside from just being a moral issue and
an environmental issue and a health
issue for humans climate change is a
national security issue and it's also an
economic issue and Donald Trump's own
administration now released a climate
change report hilariously enough they
buried it by releasing it the day after
Thanksgiving which says climate change
is real it's caused by humans and it is
a massive emergency crisis level problem
what does trump say about his own
administration's climate change report
says he doesn't believe it says he
doesn't believe this dire report about
the state of climate change from his own
administration take a look at what he
had to say when he was asked about it
the other day
I've seen it I've read some of it and
it's fine
yeah I don't believe it no no I don't
believe it and here's the other thing
you're gonna have to have China and
Japan and all of Asia and all of these
other countries you know address
addresses our country right now we're at
the cleanest we've ever been and that's
very important gentlemen but if we're
clean but every other place on earth is
dirty that's not so good so I want clean
air I want clean water very important
yeah so he's actually right that this is
not an issue that lends itself to
nationalist solutions Trump correctly
identifies if we are clean and they're
not or they're not and they are and
we're not whatever you need Global
Solutions to this issue and that's
actually what I've been saying for years
and it's one of the reasons why right
now in particular nationalist ideologies
are not going to serve us well but Trump
is asked what about the economic impact
and he says yeah well I don't believe it
this is a report from 13 federal
agencies within the Trump administration
its peer reviewed the report looks at
the economic impact as quote hundreds of
billions of dollars in annual losses to
many economic sectors if we don't act
now the report makes clear it's not just
something to deal with in the future
this is a problem now climate change is
causing more wildfires it's causing poor
air quality emissions have to be cut so
Trump believes authoritarian dictators
over our own intelligence when it comes
to Russian meddling he believes brutal
Athiya theocratic dictators over our
intelligence agencies when it comes to
the killing of Jamal khashoggi and I
guess Pat he believes I don't even know
who over his own federal agencies on the
issue of climate change I guess it's the
climate skeptics
as they call themselves we call them
deniers so none of this is new Pat a
Trump doesn't believe in climate change
but the really disturbing thing to me is
that number one even when his own
administrate
fine intelligence agencies he believes
are politically biased his own
administration's agencies are telling
him this and he still doesn't believe it
and you know what that says to me Pat
that means to me that if you say to
Trump well what evidence if we had it
would change your mind that the answer
is none because he's not dealing in fact
yeah and like you identified in Trump
identified this is the problem that has
to have some sort of global solution
well we had at least the blueprint for
that that was the Paris climate Accord
and of course Trump decided to pull out
from that so I don't know what his
alternative solution is going to be and
you're also right about how he tends to
side with foreign governments over our
own intelligence community over his own
administration well I think he's on his
own island on this one because even the
most adversarial countries around the
world to the US agree that climate
change is happening and it's a problem
that we have to solve yeah it's not even
like on this one we say Trump's position
on climate change is that of these six
authoritarian dictators from around the
world which by the way seems to be his
position on issues related to press
freedom and so many other things even
those countries recognize the reality of
climate change this is an existential
threat this climate change is an
existential threat to humanity and Trump
as someone in a position of power in
determining policy on this issue is
dangerous and the worst part about it is
that his voters aren't going to hold
them accountable which is why we need to
buy voting and I don't know if we're
going to do it I really hope that we are
send me your thoughts what do you make
of Trump not believing his own
administration's climate change report
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and boy
do we have a good program for you today
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an amazing online learning
community that offers thousands of
high-quality classes on almost any topic
first 500 people who click the link
under this video will get two entire
months of totally free access to every
single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity
I know you'll be able to find something
on Skillshare that fascinates you or
even something that will help you in
your everyday life classes are taught by
real people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up